Hey, this is a funny story. This is not like
mind blowing news worthy, but for some reason,
I love this. Fox News seems to increasingly be
having all sorts of technical problems where
people don't know that they're on the air,
their monitors go haywire, they can't hear
things. Part of it might be might be due to
some sort of socially distanced productions
that are going on where people are in different
locations during one of their shows. They come
back from commercial. And this guy, Greg Gutfeld,
who's tweeted to me in the past, started singing
about how he has to go to the bathroom.
And host Juan Williams starts a statement.
Gutfeld just sings over him that he has to pee
and people try to tell him we're live right now.
We're on the air. It doesn't seem to matter. And
then another host, Jesse Waters, makes the most
forced laugh I've maybe ever heard to pretend that
this isn't completely humiliating. Take a look.
Time now for one more thing,
I gotta pee, gotta pee.
You're on the air.
Greg, Greg,
Jesse, why don't you take this off?
Was so funny. All right, I'll take Greg
until he has to come back from the bathroom.
I want everybody to watch Fox
News this week, and I need you to.
What a time to be alive, isn't it? Now, I actually
have some thoughts about this. That might be a
different interpretation. A few viewers have been
emailing me over the last couple of weeks and
they've been saying, sir, now they said, David,
I watch this show on Fox News with Juan Williams
and Greg Gutfeld. And I keep thinking that Gutfeld
hates Juan Williams and is deliberately shunning
him on air. And for example, they sent me a clip
from the other day when Juan Williams was talking
and Gutfeld was just looking down, acting like he
was like on his phone and not even listening to
what Williams was saying. Is it possible that in
this clip, Gutfeld could hear everything fine and
he knew he was on the air, but he just wanted
to mess with Williams teleprompter read like,
I have no idea if that's what happened. But
I'm wondering merely because so many viewers
wrote to me and said Gutfeld treats Williams
horribly on this show. To be honest, this is
the most interesting thing that Greg Gutfeld has
ever said anywhere. I've never seen him be more
compelling and interesting than he was announcing
bodily functions that he needed to participate
in. His normal screeds are quite boring
and uninteresting and predictable.
This was arguably the most coherent moment
Greg Gutfeld has ever had. He needs to urinate.
He came across crystal clear. I get what he's
saying. I understand exactly what he means.
Arguably the most that he's contributed
to a segment on Fox News in years. So
that's Fox News continued technical issues.
Maybe if you believe that that's what happened